sie alle wollen auf und davon
familie aus dem thurgau sucht das große
abenteuer in australien plant hans jörg
jäger aus dem aargau bauer in thailand
eine seniorenresidenz familie tänzer aus
dem kanton bern träumt von einem
besseren leben und wagte neuanfang in
florida wiedersehen mit hermann
schönbächler
der bieler förster und seine familie
haben das glück tief im kanadischen wald
gefunden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
david masse
bevor unsere auswanderer neues leben
aufbrechen steht ihnen ein schmerzlicher
abschied bevor
so auch hans jörg jäger aus feldheim im
kanton aargau
[Applaus]
also ich war die noch viel mit wade noch
viel trara war
eine im april 2011 gegen lange und hans
jörg jäger im restaurant eines freundes
ihre große abschiedsparty
das paar ist seit 17 jahren verheiratet
jetzt ließ auge macht aber sinn möchte
damit wäre dann für hänsel insgesamt
1100 frühlingsrollen haben sie
vorbereitet vor 20 jahren verliehen
slaney ihre heimat und folgte hans
jürgen die schweiz heute verlässt er
seine heimat für einen gemeinsamen traum
sie bauen in thailand eine
seniorenresidenz
[Musik]
wir machen ja auch die größe der da wenn
hans jäger nicht gerade mit freunden auf
der harley unterwegs war arbeitete er
als physik laborant für die
kantonsschule wollen
auf ihn warten in thailand völlig neue
aufgaben
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
auch jan jäger betritt als betreiberin
einer seniorenresidenz neuland die 44
jährige arbeitete bisher als laborantin
im kantonsspital aarau
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hans joas bester freund hat zum abschied
eine rede geschrieben und nordwind und
kann da ist für das meer kollege sind
und sie verstanden weil ich sagen tun
und laune sind winter hier sind fürs
ganze
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sie haben ein schönes haus hinterher
städten im kanton thurgau
sie haben drei tolle kinder baby
jennifer den 14 jährigen kevin und den
zehnjährigen dylan und sie haben lust
auf das abenteuer ihres lebens immer und
rolf dobler wandern nach australien aus
doch der traum geht nicht für alle in
erfüllung hündin luna kann nicht
mitreisen ist sie was sie kennt und sie
ist schon etwas sie einfach zu bränden
gibt denn kaffee 20 tagen zu erleben ist
und langsam wieder an
und da wäre burka kevin und sein kleiner
bruder dylan werden bald ihren letzten
schultag in der schweiz haben
langer hat ein neues plätzchen und zwei
neue freunde gefunden
eine bekannte der australien
auswanderern in den hund bei sich auf
[Musik]
rolf dobler ist bodenleger vor einigen
jahren gründete er seine eigene firma
immer besorgte von zu hause aus die
büroarbeiten
die geschäfte liefen gut alles perfekt
läuft alles sind da wäre jetzt auch die
nächsten jahre so weiter und wäre so
laufer und da ich dadurch zusätzliche
städte lusaka bringt damit dem geschäft
ich haben uns zuvor berichtet karin wohl
spannung sich vor allem am 8 und jetzt
läuft und da haben wir nicht vorstellen
dass er viel zeit immer so weitergehe
könne macht und nicht immer werden wir
einen weiten leeren es anders
seinen showroom hat der 44-jährige
geräumt und die firma hat er einem
kollegen verkauft
[Musik]
hat sich eine lustige zauber in die
natur und zweigen wirtschaft verträge
weg aber jede mannschaft die während
sich seine gemacht das spital welt
informierten über die wieder als lehrer
für verschiedene huster vivaldi xi und
klein fatale liebe erzählen
darauf haben wir auf ich war von mir
kennt oder nicht da jedoch noch passabel
auf solltest du aus bremen bevor immer
tobler zu ihrem rolf in den thurgau zug
lebte die gebürtige spanierin auf
teneriffa am anfang alles ist so
dermaßen gut laufen und jetzt habe ich
wirklich richtige bremsen nicht nervös
sie freut sich riesig auf der neuen
celebrity eine neue schule neue sind
woanders hin nach lienz eingeht und neue
freundschaften kinder machen und die
diebe freut sich weil ein umzugs
container auf die andere seite der erde
viel zu teuer wäre verkaufen die tobias
ihr hab und gut
dass sie eine der begehrten
aufenthaltsbewilligungen für australien
bekamen haben die auswanderer rolfs job
zu verdanken bodenleger steht auf einer
liste mit gesuchten berufen
die nachricht die ihr leben auf den kopf
stellen sollte bestand aus wenigen
worten nowy sacz findet ihr visumsantrag
wurde genehmigt
eine pdf datei von den hartz iv gemacht
und hans-joachim gründet mit der ganze
dokumentation alles drin oder war
irgendwie viel passiert
[Musik]
das haus bleibt übrigens in der familie
rolf dobler bruder hat es gekauft
[Musik]
wer ihn hönebach im kanton bern wohnt
hat das paradies gefunden würde man
meinen doch dennis und clyde dancer
zieht es ins land der unbegrenzten
möglichkeiten ihr paradies heißt amerika
ihr haus an bester lage über dem
thunersee haben sie bereits verkauft
gemeinsam mit ihren töchtern franke und
larissa wollen sie in florida noch
einmal von vorne anfangen und eine neue
existenz aufbauen
[Musik]
hamster topf ist zu alt für die reise
über den großen teich er bleibt hier und
wird viel verpassen
dessen sind sich larissa und franca seit
ihrer letzten ferien reise durch die usa
sicher sofort ja
clyde denzer ist geschäftsführer einer
großen autogarage doch jetzt hat der
41-jährige die nase voll
was ist im rückblick vom arbeitsplatz
ancelotti steht in japan aber viel
größer kick
im lappe und und ich brauche diesen
trick verrät für der wieder mal jährigen
warf hochform auflaufen und und
motiviert sie ist ein so großer
langweiligen alltag
[Musik]
die langeweile ist vorbei aus ihrem haus
müssen sie ausziehen und clyde hat bald
seinen letzten arbeitstag im dezember
2010 fliegen tennis und clyde denzer
vorerst ohne ihre töchter nach florida
[Musik]
bevor die bündnerin und der berner
auswandern können müssen sie wissen wo
sie überhaupt leben und wie sie ihr geld
verdienen werden
also schnell ich alles
[Musik]
mit dem verstand im moment nicht ihnen
also dass ich viel schneller
die auswanderer wollen ihr geld aus dem
hausverkauf in der schweiz in einem
typisch amerikanischen mobile homepark
einen dauer campingplatz investieren
dann könnten sie von den mieteinnahmen
leben und gleich selber in einem der
mobile homes wohnen eine deutsche
autorin hilft ihnen bei der suche
[Musik]
bonnie und clyde denken mit wehmut an
ihr haus das sie bereits verkauft haben
in hönebach ging der blick in die
malerischen berge immerhin verspricht
der besitzer jährliche mieteinnahmen von
40.000 dollar
[Musik]
die gegend werde regelrecht explodieren
vergnügungspark hotelkomplex schlicht
ein mekka für touristen werde hier
entstehen
[Musik]
geschickt
sich einfach nur schlimm dass die
rohstoffe
[Musik]
er macht das wie duras mannschaft
der förster hermann schönbächler und
seine frau christine leben seit zwei
jahren im kanadischen rosberg mit ihrem
sohn regier und ihrer tochter natascha
führen sie jenes leben von dem sie immer
geträumt haben vor einem jahr macht der
baby alexandra das familienglück perfekt
ihr tief im wald ist die schweiz nur
mehr eine ferne erinnerung dass ich mir
ging es macht es im grund genau da sie
nicht muss schaffe und bickel im grund
genug für nummer für die zinszahlung für
krankenkasse zahlen für satz zahlen für
versicherungen für abkassiert werden
[Musik]
hermann schönbächler hat sich in kanada
ein paradies geschaffen als gläubiger
man weiß aber dass es da oben einen gibt
der das schicksal auf wären leitet und
das schicksal hat familie schönbächler
hart getroffen
was der förster vor einem jahr erleben
muss der erschütterte ihn zutiefst ein
jahrhundert sturm zerstört der große
teile seiner existenzgrundlage
[Musik]
es entstand bei warum das mit der haider
sich nebst günstigen
lebenshaltungskosten abstieg günstige
immobilienpreise nach schöner geografie
ist der grundstock versichert der arbeit
eigentlich auf die nächsten 20 jahre das
ist jetzt das volumen ist
hermann schönbächler arbeitet für einen
wald pächter doch seit dem sturm ist
eine geregelte arbeit im wald kaum mehr
möglich
da jetzt schon bisher gewalt nicht
blockieren aber blieb mit
bereitschaftsleiter wenig so haben meine
kenntnisse weiter die jahrgänge bis zu
dir
[Musik]
zurück in die schweiz nach veltheim im
kanton aargau
hier lebt thailand auswanderer und
harley fan hans jörg jäger mit seiner
frau lange und fest
das blatt
jeder holt ihr wichtigstes gepäckstück
aus dem keller
hoffen auf sie noch so lange gespart
[Musik]
saubere
lobby
[Musik]
mini audi verkauft weil da hat gerade
das bungalow kein teil und sie hat mir
schon weg macht darauf der andere sie
denn ich zahle 180% luxussteuer und den
han i gaal verzichtet durfte aus und ja
mit dem buch noch honig verdienen mit
der halleiner
[Musik]
während einer ferienreise verlebte sich
familie tobler in die kleinstadt shelton
hier wie sie leben
[Musik]
rolf dobler und sein 14 jähriger sohn
kevin sind nach australien vorausgereist
in der nächsten tagen müssen sie ein
haus für die familie finden mutter immer
und die beiden kleineren kinder sind
noch in der schweiz
sie kommen in zwei wochen nach dem
überraschend guten champagner trinken zu
marschieren das mache ich mal einfach
wie der kredite aufnehmen kann
champagner trinken kurz team und er hat
den zauber die schweiz hat acht meter
auf der sich verantwortlich fühlt sich
gleich am ersten tag haben die
abenteurer ein auto und einen
zeltanhänger gekauft
ja also wegen sondern sich in die haare
lang sind
[Musik]
nach vier stunden fahrt kommen vater und
sohn in shelton an die kleinstadt hat
rund 40.000 einwohner
nur gesamt allgemein größerer wesley
kris boyd sehen wenn wir zum lied räume
kulisse aber wir sind wie möglich sehr
schön
wir hoffen dass marx günstigste mir dass
ich einmal fürs erste jahr oder so aber
im moment sieht man sich ob das klappen
bis sie ein haus gefunden haben werden
die auswanderer auf dem campingplatz
wohnen
[Musik]
der oca sie uns zeltanhänger hat 13
tausend franken gekostet
alle kunden dienen kienast wenn wir
genug war zum erfolg 97 die meisten
linien camping trailer auf das was so
richtig ja jetzt wenn man halt die sache
aber nass wurde sind die zimmer rechts
sprechen jetzt mehr glück dass weitere
im moment ganz okay ich das endlich
achtung endete jetzt hoffen und was hat
mein team auf deine mensch laufen
[Musik]
nein ich mache
nur gezählt mehr und will allianzen von
ich hoffe schon dass daher
hey channel switches ok
[Musik]
nein
stoffwechsel
[Musik]
die dauer campingplätze die kommission
kleid denzer besichtigt haben waren eine
enttäuschung
doch die zeit drängt kleid hat seinen
job gekündigt und sein haus verkauft
bevor er wusste wie das neue leben in
florida aussehen soll
mit seinem überstürzten vorgehen hat er
seine frau dawn ist viel verständnis
abverlangt
das ist viel zeit das überraschte noch
nicht geklärt
aber die haben eine birke erle bereits
schweigert
profitieren
mittlerweile hat bestellt und freue mich
auf das abenteuer ja nicht unbedingt
behaupten
aber das hat sich sichere durchschlag
und er hat - orientiert an ihm gezeigt
so etwas hat stark gemacht
mit dem etat muss ein gesetz das das sie
und heute
[Musik]
[Applaus]
deutsche zugang
hätte ich jetzt gesehen
seine musik
diese grundstücke der müsli indiana
jones zudem
schließlich 420 gefühl für den ski
cracks
oder ist es schon 5 306 die im krieg ja
noch etwas zu tun
aber ich denke hier ist wie beim
lakeside gemacht ein gelände oder etwas
daraus machen kannst als ich draußen
teeren und
begeisterung klingt anders
immerhin suchen die auswanderer ein
neues zuhause wo sie glücklich werden
wollen
[Applaus]
ja egal ob sie mit einer flanke
die welt ist
die generierte dennis tänzer hat ganz
besondere pläne
[Applaus]
ja
immer wenn er wegschaue abgeht stöckli
wird zusätzlicher
zum beispiel warum ist das halt du
[Musik]
die auswanderer waren aufgebrochen um
ein neues zuhause zu finden
doch ihre töchter die vorerst in der
schweiz geblieben sind warten vergeblich
auf gute nachrichten aus florida so
schwierig hatten sich dennis und clyde
denzer den start in ihr neues leben
nicht vorgestellt
[Musik]
was geschieht danach
optisch setzt
[Musik]
dennis tänzer hadert solche ausblicke
hatte sie im kopf weil sie sich
überreden ließ in der schweiz alles
aufzugeben
das hat ja daheim nie beweisen dass ich
es noch nicht so kühl lupe nahm
sich
bis das republik wie schaut es ist alles
vorhanden
für dich
hallo wer nicht
[Musik]
am nächsten tag werden die auswanderer
erfahren dass es auf dem einzigen
campingplatz der ihnen einigermaßen
gefallen hat eine schießerei zwischen
verfeindeten drogenbanden gegeben hat
[Musik]
nach dem verheerenden sturm vor einem
jahr hat hermann schönbächler unzählige
umgeknickte bäume entastet bevor er
weiter arbeiten kann muss er warten bis
dieser abtransportiert sind dafür hat er
nun mehr zeit für die familie und für
projekte rund ums haus sie mit dem wort
das mit der welt positionieren
wenn wir das inzwischen schneller
werkstoff porzellan
wir haben das heu medizincheck
die frage ist so was man morgen ist die
messe wikinger so oder so mit dem zu
müssen gut sagen hören
[Musik]
deswegen bin ich also das männliche weg
vom spiel hässlich
[Musik]
die zone forschung
und um heilige recht
[Musik]
flughafen kloten im letzten april dani
und hansjörg eger müssen sich von ihren
liebsten verabschiedet
ja nicht gut gefühlt in diesem moment
war auf wiedersehen sagen aber gehörte
sogar von der labour muss muss wer
akzeptiert dann ja nur viel ein kurzer
moment daher freue mich zum anderen
mache ja einmal ein vielfaches verdienen
ja
zum abschied kommt auch tochter fern mit
ihrem freund die 25 jährige wird in der
schweiz bleiben
[Musik]
ansehnlich
[Applaus]
[Musik]
du bist nicht allein
zuvor geht es in einer woche weiter nach
dem schweren abschied der herzliche
empfang lange und hansjörg eger treffen
in thailand ein auf der baustelle nimmt
ihre seniorenresidenz erste formen an
in kanada genießen christine und hermann
schönbächler
die viel beschworene ultimative
lebensqualität
bonnie und clyde dancer suchen in
florida noch immer ihr glück
[Musik]
und rolf von kevin tobler wohnen in
australien auf dem campingplatz der
thurgauer meldet seiner frau in die
schweiz ersuche unermüdlich nach einem
haus
[Musik]
muss ich die gerne
träumen
die wiener
rostock
[Musik]